is talking to Kim Jong-un all right and
where he reluctantly accepted a Tic Tac
from Trump who dramatically blew it in
the air to reassure Kim that it was a
breath met and not a capsule poison
think about it Trump had to go look I'm
not dead so they talked about Sports
women's soccer then Sanders say she
looked up to notice Kim Kim jung-un is
staring at her cuz she's hot uh and um
he appeared to wink at me and she
appeared stunned right Sarah Huckabee
Sanders Sarah Huckabee Sanders Kim
Jong-un looked at her with his dope ass
hair kind of went and winked at her so
she goes all I could think was what just
happened surely Kim jung-un did not just
Mark me then later in the presidential
limousine the beast on the way to the
airport Sanders tells you know Trump
like Kim Jung and Trump was like he hit
on you he did he effing hit on you and
then she goes sir please stop you know
what Trump says to her well Sarah that
settles it you're going to North Korea
and you're taking one for the team